in the opening scene we are introduced
to 16 year old girl Rin who is in the
middle of her pilgrimage on her way she
comes across a couple of elderly women
who give her a good luck Bell she
attaches it to her backpack and
continues her journey through the forest
following simple carved stones and
visiting various temples on Route the
scene then shifts to a couple of years
back we see a 13 year old Ren who lives
with her grandmother in a small Hut
somewhere at Mount ishizuki one day she
hunts down a rabbit and runs home
excited to cook a delicious meal however
her Elation turns to shock as she
discovers that her grandmother has
passed away this leaves the girl clearly
distraught causing her to break down in
tears overwhelmed with grief Rin recalls
her Grandma's words about having to
leave the world one day her Grandma
seems to have taught her a valuable
lesson regarding the importance of doing
good to others in order to receive good
in return tell that to the rabbit in the
morning as Rin goes to the nearby River
to fetch water she comes across a
villager who inquires about her
grandmother Rin who fears that the
villagers will take her grandma away
hides the truth and pretends that she is
fine but despite her efforts the man
senses something is amiss so he secretly
follows her back home upon arriving her
Wren starts to prepare a grave for her
shortly after she locks all the doors
and windows before venturing outside to
gather some wood as soon as she leaves
the same villager walks to the door and
peeps inside through a hole only to
discover the lifeless body of Jima in
the next scene Rin returns home with
firewood and finds that the man is
broken into the house he confronts Wren
about the situation but the girl starts
to beat him up in Rage and sends him
away claiming that she won't let the
villagers take her grandma away from her
afterwards the man notifies all the
villagers who then capture Rin in an
abandoned stable tying her to a pillar
the villagers expressed their discontent
with their choices and berate her for
hiding her grandmother's passing
following this the local residents
transport the grandmother to a nearby
Temple for proper funeral rights
meanwhile within the stable Rin hears
her grandmother's voice offering
reassurance that she will always be by
her side she also offers words of Solace
and encouragement in order to bolster
her granddaughter's Spirit a few days
later while cooking rabbit soup those
rabbits don't catch a break Rin is
visited by a man named sakichi from
another Village he strikes up a
conversation with Ren showing interest
in learning more about her amidst this
Ren offers him some of her rabbit soup
which earns her praise for its delicious
taste continuing with the conversation
he delves further inquiring about her
Hobbies Rin reveals that she skillfully
hunts rabbits you don't say and hides
them away in the mountains hearing this
sakichi proposes to buy all of her
rabbits in exchange for money a deal
which she agrees to immediately I'd kill
them all for free she says as they
continue chatting sikichi asks if she
wants to live a lavish life Rin says yes
and asks how it is possible tsukichi
then extends an invitation for her to
accompany him to an island where she can
have a job and live a good life at this
moment Rin is suddenly reminded of her
grandmother's stories about people who
exploit poor families selling innocent
girls into laborious faiths hence she
declines tsukishi's offer and asks him
to leave the following day sakichi
approaches Rin and attempts to convince
her one more time this time he
highlights the possibility of earning
sufficient enough money to build a
decent grave for her grandmother he also
says that she can enjoy the Magnificent
sea hearing all this Rin is finally
convinced and she accompanies tsukichi
to an island called mitarai on their way
they come across a picturesque Beach and
Rin who has never before witnessed such
an ocean becomes speechless overwhelmed
with excitement she runs in the water
rolls along the beach and joyfully plays
with the sand wait until she finds out
there's no rabbits here the scene then
shifts to a few days later and we see
Rin who is now sold to a brothel house
in mithurai Island there she is assigned
with the various chores including
cooking cleaning and so on for the first
few days she is unable to adapt to the
new environment so she remains secluded
in her room without eating or talking to
anyone seeing her behavior the brothel
owners who are a couple chastise her for
her stubbornness one day she is
approached by another girl named ASA who
works as a shop clerk on the island Rin
likes her nature so she quickly
befriends her ASA imparts some important
lessons to Ren explaining that she can
return only if she works hard and
complies with the owners encouraged by
this Insight Rin from the very next day
on begins to carry out all of the tasks
such as washing clothes mopping floors
and serving the owner's needs one day
Ren is mistreated by a customer and she
responds by splashing him with a bucket
of water as a consequence the owner
punishes Rin for her arrogance by
subjecting her to a cruel thrashing
despite the physical reprimand Rin
remains outwardly composed acting as if
she wasn't affected shortly after the
lady owner intervenes and suggests that
Rin might be managing boats the owner
immediately likes the idea and they
decide to give rin a new job the
following day Rin heads to the Shoreline
where she meets a man named shohei who
owns a boat she requests that he teach
her to row the boat with her great
interest and passion in this she quickly
grasps the skill and is soon prepared to
engage in the boat business after a few
days she is assigned to transport the
brothel's sisters to the fisherman's
ship witnessing her working as a rower
ASA gets curious about her intentions so
she inquires if Rin wants to escape
however our girl answers with a no
stating that her actions are driven
solely by her personal interests during
rainy evening the lady owner expresses
her concern about the declining business
due to rain hearing this Rin comes up
with a strategy of her own she asserts
That Rainy Days offer a unique
opportunity to make good profits since
there will be no competition she also
assures the owner that she can
skillfully row about even in heavy rain
with confidence in her capabilities the
owner grants her permission to proceed
and just like that Wren starts ferrying
the sisters to the fisherman's ship
despite the adverse conditions this
Garners her a lot of Praise from
everyone especially the fishermen who
love kicking it to Rainy Mood lofi beats
so they reward her with some money as
days pass by the sisters in the Brothel
House Express their displeasure
regarding the quality of meals Rin is
prepared sparking a confrontation this
leads Ren to Loser temper prompting her
to storm away she runs to a hill and
rests under a tree during this time she
experiences her first menstruation cycle
which sets her off into a state of panic
as she begins Crying In Fear a generous
woman approaches her and offers
assistance she takes her into her home
and helps her clean up and at this
moment Wren Sharon about her loneliness
and the absence of someone to share such
experiences with in the next scene Rin
meets shohei who is returning from the
sea with a catch of fish in his net
seeing this she asks him to release the
fish back into the water because she can
relate to these fishes sharing the
feeling of being trapped shohei
surprisingly agrees with her which is
dumb because they need to eat but it
makes Wren feel happy she then leans
into the fisherman's arms sparking a
romantic relationship they still don't
have food though later in the evening
Rin is in the middle of her work when
the owner summons her it becomes
apparent that they are aware of her
transition into Womanhood through her
menstruation cycle they Rejoice at the
belief that they have gained a new
sister for their Brothel House Furious
Rin refuses to be a prostitute and
claims that she'll never engage with any
customers this infuriates the owner who
then subjects her to a brutal punishment
with her body full of bruises and blood
Ren goes to meet shohei she pleads with
him to take her away from the island and
for this she is ready to do everything
he wants she even agrees to sleep with
him for free despite seeing her in such
a situation Joe hay can do nothing as he
needs more money to buy a new boat that
can take them away from the island now
with no one else to rely on Rin takes
matters into her own hands she cuts her
hair so that she will look ugly and
won't have to serve as a brothel sister
the owners are enraged by her behavior
but they can do nothing but let her work
as a rower one morning sakichi makes a
visit to the Brothel House upon seeing
him Ren pretends to be nice and extends
an invitation to enjoy some hot drinks
as well as to be the first customer of
the day but once takichi settles in she
abruptly chokes him nearly taking his
life sakishi somehow manages to free
himself and quickly runs away in panic
later that same day Rin is approached by
ASA who informs her of sukichi's death
both Rin and ASA seem to find a sense of
satisfaction in his demise as he is the
reason why they all ended up in a
brothel house in the evening Rin meets
with an elderly man who presents her
with a gift intrigued by his unexpected
generosity she inquires why he is being
nice to her to which the elderly man
responds that he values her
straightforwardness he offers her a safe
space to vent her frustrations prom
support her through it all after the man
departs the owner's Informer in that the
elderly man is an executive of a trade
Union who wants to buy her on contract
Wren however firmly rejects the
proposition following this she retreats
to the woods and lays down beneath a
tree during this quiet moment she hears
her grandmother's voice encouraging her
to return to the mountains a few moments
later she makes her way back to the
Brothel House where she comes across a
man a pastor with a boat on the
shoreline Wren rushes towards him and
pleads with him to take her along
anywhere he might be heading although
the man genuinely wants to help her he
explains that their current lack of
funds prevents an immediate Escape he
tells her to wait for him assuring that
he will come back for her rescue the
refusal upsets her in prompting her to
walk away sadly several months pass and
Rin reluctantly begins to engage in the
tasks assigned by the owners her
youthful appearance draws in a
substantial number of customers given
that the world is a broken ass place
which leads her to become the number one
worker of the Brothel House despite this
she remains her bold personality and she
doesn't tolerate any physical violence
one day renway up to find a world
shrouded in darkness initially mistaking
it for night time she soon realizes that
she has lost her sight despite her
predicament she tries her best to act
normal so that she won't be dominated by
others but unlike before Rin is helpless
when it comes to defending herself
seeking assistants Rin visits an eye
doctor who delivers disheartening news
her right eye has completely lost its
sight while her Left Eye's vision is
limited to a mere 30 centimeters this
devastates her in as she lacks money for
treatment when she returns to the
brothel her fellow sisters sent
something amiss and ask about her eyes
Rin confidently claims that her vision
is indeed clear one of the sisters
challenges her to prove it by rowing the
boat and our girl agrees to it after
this Rin along with the other sisters
sets off to the sea but unfortunately
Rin is unable to control the boat like
she used to which ultimately causes the
sisters to fall into the water as days
pass by the owners grow increasingly
concerned about their business as Rin is
no longer able to attract customers as
before witnessing her play NASA
approaches Rin and inquires if
everything is alright though initially
has it Rin finally reveals about her
deteriorating eyesight in response ASA
proposes that Ren and bark on a
pilgrimage and escape the island however
Rin seems to have given up on all her
aspirations due to her blindness one day
Rin hears a voice calling her to a
temple offering herbal tea initially she
ignores the call but after a lot of
contemplating she runs outside she makes
her way to the shore where the pastor is
waiting for her Rin is unable to figure
out his identity because of her
blindness so she asks his name the
pastor doesn't disclose anything and
guides her to a boat revealing that he
is fulfilling her desire to leave the
island he hands her money and advises
her to become a pilgrim suggesting it
might Aid in restoring her eyesight in
the final scene Ren is seen exploring
temples as depicted in the opening
moment as night descends she seeks a
place to rest only to be haunted by
dreams of fire vividly reliving the past
brutalities she endure with the arrival
of the next sunrise Rin awakens and
continues her pilgrimage Journey
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching